Buenas tardes gran paso histórico para
Finlandia como comentabas en Rosa
Finlandia ha entregado formalmente los
documentos en que certifican su adhesión
a la organización lo ha hecho después de
que Turquía haya dado su visto bueno a
Estados Unidos como garante del tratado
fundacional en que ha explicado su en
que ha dado su visto bueno Y también ha
dado también su formalización para que
Finlandia pudiera ser un miembro
Finlandia con este paso histórico da
carpetazo a su política de neutralidad
política exterior el secretario de
estado Anthony blinken ha confirmado
esta entrega de los documentos por parte
de Turquía y de Finlandia y tras ellos
se ha ido la bandera por primera vez de
Finlandia aquí en la sede central de la
otan en Bruselas con esta con esta izado
de la bandera Finlandia se convierte así
en el país trigésimo primero de la otan
aunque se espera que pronto puedan ser
más y Esther estábamos viendo estas
imágenes no de Cómo se dice la bandera
de Finlandia pero la bandera que no se
hizo es la de Suecia a pesar de que
presentó su candidatura a la otan con
Finlandia pero recordemos que la
aspiración sueca está bloqueada sobre
todo por Turquía principalmente Qué se
sabe de este proceso de esta candidatura
de Suecia la otan
Sí así es Finlandia confiaba en que
pudiera entrar en la otan junto a Suecia
el otro país nórdico de hecho hicieron
su entrega formal el pasado mayo y en
junio se les invitó a ambos países a
poder ser países miembros pero aún falta
el proceso de ratificación Turquía y
Hungría una han rectificado esta entrada
por parte de Suecia a la otan porque por
diversas razones por una parte está
Turquía que considera que Suecia aunado
suficientes garantías por atajar el
terrorismo kurdo porque considera que da
cobijo a terroristas del partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán en su terreno
Por otra parte Hungría se siente molesta
porque considera que Suecia ha sido muy
crítica con la política del Primer
Ministro Víctor Urban en cualquier caso
el secretario general de la otanberg se
ha mostrado convencido de que Suecia
pronto va a poderse convertir en Nuevo
miembro de la otan de hecho ya ha
avanzado que relanzará las
conversaciones para que pronto pueda ser
pueda ser así